hey what's going on YouTube I know this
is a little different from the normal
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] air conditioning
is loud
well you guys are got some pretty
exciting news I'm about to be on a
platform called vessel God you guys
already armed vessel and you guys
already know about it go ahead and
subscribe to me at vessel comm slash
Davis o comedy because I'll be dead I'm
gonna flap them but basically what
vessel you guys will be able to see my
content five days earlier than you will
on YouTube now puppy shut up got a puppy
we're [ __ ] marking all over the place
oh [ __ ] so when you guys do sign up for
vessel guess what the first month is
free and then after that is $2.99 and if
you find out that you don't want to
[ __ ] be on it then you can just
unsubscribe and either way you still got
to see like a [ __ ] ton of my videos
ahead of time before that one month and
so it's a win-win situation if you guys
stay on you guys support me you'll help
me out thank you very much and of course
I'm gonna give you guys better [ __ ]
content which means short films which
means I could pay these [ __ ]
stead of asking for favors cuz I think
they started hating me now for me if you
guys are tell me why I don't want to be
on [ __ ] vessel [ __ ] you David
well [ __ ] you too nobody's forcing you
[ __ ] there's not a good way to people
on a platform so even if you don't sign
up for vessel guess what you can still
see my [ __ ] on YouTube but if you do
want to stay on vessel subscribe to me
and you guys will be helping me out and
put out some dope-ass content yeah short
films [ __ ] but yes I will see
you guys this Sunday and of course I
will see y'all on vessel as well by the
Italian that's how early you get to see
the content she's crazy bomb
yes it [ __ ] is hey what's going on
YouTube well now if you haven't heard
about vessel vessel is a pretty dope
what the foot